so i'm sure we will remember konami's
world famous yu-gi-oh
card trading game right came out in
about 1999 and into the early naughties
and subsequently my childhood this game
somehow ended up as my playground
livelihood
[Music]
and to this day i have vivid memories of
trading these guards with my schoolmates
under the little fire escape stairwell
of our primary school always hearing
rumors about egyptian god cards floating
around the school and you know there's
actually an online yugioh pack opening
simulator that i found out about
recently which lets you relive those
childhood memories of opening that crisp
metallic plastic bag and slowly turning
over the cards one by one to see what
you got it really fills the late night
air with nostalgia
[Music]
anyway a few years later such a trend
would be replaced with gogo's crazy
bones now these small plastic figurines
brought card trading into the third
dimension and instead of dex we came to
school with small hop sack bags filled
with colorful fascinating little
monsters now these things are actually
quite expensive so you'd always find
some random knock-off gogos around the
school that would basically ruin the
reputation of the owner but
interestingly enough i never actually
knew how to play any of these associated
games nine-year-old me was simply
infatuated by the social influence
prestige and romanticism that these
assets carried now of course i couldn't
stay in school forever so these were the
only two trends that really stuck out
for me but i'd be naive to suggest that
these trends wouldn't keep popping up
and developing over time however i never
thought they'd go as far as they have my
step-brother who i would have expected
to be playing yu-gi-oh at his age now
has his own nft via his mother's binance
account confirming that these playground
trends have moved into the fourth
dimension even further or perhaps
they've regressed into something more
sinister emblematic of the spreading
gangrene there's the ironically
de-socializing world of social media
indeed that's the question that we'll be
focusing on today are nfts safe for our
developing youngsters i'm bradley peake
this is some sub and let's get into it
[Music]
so as we've briefly discussed in the
introduction nfts fit a variety of
criteria that suit the crazes of younger
generations i mean they're colorful
unique tradable and collectible with a
backdrop of technological cogs and wires
enticing a sense of mystery which really
suits the needs and desires of the
younger cohort let's say under the age
of 13. however they're also being hailed
as trendy off-piste rebellious and
ultimately quick ways of making money
which appeals to the needs and desires
of the older group let's say those you
know within the age group of 13 to 18.
and you know i'm not the only one to
notice that nfts seem to fit the
criteria for playground trends funko a
company traded on the nasdaq which has
traditionally made plushen action toys
vinyl figurines and accessories made
their foray into nfts last year by
acquiring a major ownership stake in
tokenwave now the company's making their
nfts easily tradable on a variety of
different mobile platforms but what
about those kids that are into sports
those who would have otherwise traded
say match a tax cards in the late
noughties well sporting nfts have also
joined the party too with companies such
as nba top shot offering nfts starting
at a dollar each now the low prices of
some of these nfts shouldn't be
underestimated as a factor for their
adoption right as they provide a
weigh-in for kids who don't even get
minimum wage for their summer laboring
jobs and also moving into the realm of
teenager hood the fact that these nfts
can be sold at a higher price is an
incredibly attractive factor instead of
rumors about hot cards circulating the
school you're listening to rumors of
kids making cold hard cash for simply
holding the right token for long enough
now in a world where impressing the
opposite sex is paramount buying an nft
may be your fast trained ticket to that
brand new pair of gucci trainers and a
date with maria from math class it's
also worth mentioning that kids idolize
celebrities and are a great target
market for things such as signed posters
right and merchandise and is it really
such a surprise that everyone under the
age of 16 is looking to get their hands
on a bayc nft with holders such as
justin bieber little baby and snoop dogg
but lastly we shouldn't forget about the
psychological aspect here if the
american psychological association has
confirmed that a key side effect of
puberty is parental conflict through
seeking greater independence and there's
no better way of achieving independence
than getting involved with something
that your parents aren't able to
understand right yes i'm sure they'll
forgive you for your d in physics when
you've just sold a picture of a shoe for
fifteen thousand dollars
[Music]
now a big question here relates to the
effect that nfts are having on future
generations and this is really the focus
of today's video there can be no doubt
that a yu-gi-oh obsession wouldn't lead
a child to a life of crime but can we
say the same for nfts
many are quick to point out the benefits
right by being plunged into a market
where you can lose all of your savings
through one bad trade or win big through
maybe thorough due diligence kids are
taught the value of money early on when
they aren't playing with say big sums of
money at all they can learn the
relationships between supply and demand
and with terms such as liquidity pools
d5 market maker in the vocabulary a 15
year old is well on his way to a degree
in economics but the biggest problem
here comes with the bad habits that can
be cultivated through an nfc obsession
studies actually show that increased
screen time alone can lead to a lack of
social activity and physical activity
leading to inadequate sleep poor grades
and a greater risk of obesity indeed
teens who are on their phones for more
than several hours a day are more likely
to suffer from mental health issues than
those who spend an hour or less per day
no doubt by sitting inside staring at
the price of your nft as opposed to
running around with your mates playing
football is going to have a negative
effect on all aspects of your
psychological development another cited
benefit here is the added value that's
placed on creativity there are truly
fascinating cases of children making
real money through their own artistic
talent take benjamin ahmed as an example
a 12 year old coder who last year made
international headlines with the launch
of his own 3 350 piece nft collection
which was named weird wales now
regardless of the money he made here
which was considerable this has served
as a real piece of inspiration for the
younger generation who are now flooding
the world of digital art on mass i was
posting coding videos on youtube that
very few people watched
so as you can imagine it's a bit of a
shock to be now talking on stage at such
a venue indeed back in 2004 i could
never dream of creating my own yu-gi-oh
card while now the sky is the limit as
far as kids are concerned with the
foundations being set for a vast number
of careers that will really be central
to the world of web 3. the words
creativity inspiration and freedom
definitely come to mind here
notwithstanding the undeniable influx of
creative organs afloat i can't help
noting the skepticism in web3 even by
industry dreadnought such as musk it
seems a bit risky getting hyped up about
something that has been time and time
again cited as tulipmania there's
already a shortage of teachers nurses
care workers and veterinarians in the uk
with over 1.1 million fewer people in
the workplace than there would have been
if pre-pandemic trends would have
continued are we sure that we really
want more people dropping out of school
because they've made a little money on
nfcs and they'd like to see where it
goes
well first of all it's important to
point out here that anyone under the age
of 18 can't actually legally trade
crypto or even set up a wallet that will
hold the nfts themselves of course
exchanges are plagued with similarities
to gambling in terms of risks so of
course they're heavily regulated but
much like signing up for facebook under
your mum's email address in 2008 to play
farmville it's not stopping anyone
however this can actually be seen as a
benefit parents will have ultimate
control over what their child is buying
and we'll also be able to guide them
while teaching them valuable lessons
such as portfolio diversification where
the child will learn that it's better to
hold on to say 100 us dollars in the
form of a few different assets instead
of just one and this is very similar to
what students of gcse business studies
would learn when analyzing something
called the boston matrix now this is
actually a pretty simple model that puts
a businesses brands projects or products
into four distinct categories now a star
is a product let's say which has a high
relative market share and a high market
growth rate if a child wants to put a
star into their portfolio they might
look at getting some apecoin right this
is a new asset with a high growth
potential from the bayc
next we've got cash cows now these have
a low rate of growth but a high market
share a great example of a cash cow in
your say portfolio could be ethereum
these are really things that are going
to be long-term investment assets
now we've got the question marks now
these are really where you can have some
fun these are your meme coins and just
all-round crazy utility tokens i'd
probably put something stupid in here
like pump it bogdanoff twins inspired
meme coin with launchpad utility i don't
know
lastly we've got the dogs now dogs
aren't put into your boston matrix on
purpose but things do become dogs over
time and they'll probably sit in your
portfolio until they become question
marks right or just be removed
altogether
now we all have these assets right now
curved dao tokens would probably be good
examples so look you don't even need to
revise this model if you're learning how
to diversify a portfolio practically
right and this means the kids will be
able to draw on their practical
experience when entering an internship
at a hedge fund for example but the
problems arise when parents take a lasse
fair approach and leave tiktok to dish
out the economics advice instead the
platform known for its incredibly
inflammatory scam-filled investment
advice targeted teens with a view
counter in mind now i'm sure one could
argue that it's good for their kids to
learn lessons the hard way and maybe
lose a bit of money as per this advice
but
well we sure it's a valuable lesson if
it comes at the cost of their mental
health an economics as level is all that
is really needed to understand why
influencer-led investment advice is
largely bogus so in short there's no
excuse here for lazy parenting something
that really makes up the cohort of
parenting sadly these days
now look much like yugioh cards i expect
that nfts are a trend that will come and
go sure they will have their place on
the blockchain for its entity just like
mediocre rappers have their place on
soundcloud but i doubt that we'll be
seeing assets that are lacking in
intrinsic value taking the place of
anything other than say a luxury good on
the economic spectrum succumbing to all
natural economic forces much like anyone
it's important that children with brains
as malleable and valuable as gold
shouldn't be sold the investor's dream
it's clear that we're coaxing in the new
generation into the workplace with
myriad of mental health issues that we
ourselves have cultivated and it's just
not fair on them now i'm not saying
let's go back to 1999 but for pete's
sake our kids are not fungible well
anyway my name is bradley peak and for
the sake of nostalgia let me know in the
comments what you used to bring to
school to trade with your friends back
in the day i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
you